les gondoles sont amarrés bercer par le
doux mouvement des eaux
ce n'est pas la beauté de la scène qui
s'offrent aux regards qui est
extraordinaire quoique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais plutôt ce qu'on n'y voit pas venise
sans touristes ou si peu et belle
rebelle automnale et à lavaur à l
automne a raconté l'adjoint aux travaux
l'eau et ils contactent aux collégiens
est allé cosy librairies et des et de
belles la belle impression
alberto pavaner gondolier de père en
fils il est de retour à la ram de son
embarcation emblématique pour la
première fois en deux mois ce matin 500
touristes pour cerveau sont produits
vers l'ontario de malongo jeux cérébraux
très bon gros problème c'est non c'est
non si tu auras à la normale et à you
credo qui tenta tentatives et à roubaix
challenge en difficulté à marquer parce
que comme quoi dire fier de son nom car
oui les spurs sont tentés et sinon très
sérieusement si morlaix
la cité des doges et fasse un paradoxe
elle qui craignait hier de crouler sous
le poids des touristes semblent
aujourd'hui condamnée par leur absence
l'an passé ils ont été une trentaine de
millions de visiteurs a foulé les pavés
des rues étroites et sillonner les
canaux mais après deux mois de
quarantaine
on craint de ne plus les revoir avant
longtemps mais son logo dota et canal
on avait des céréales et une chorale et
bordeaux sur le rubygate diagne d'être
mobilisés mais pennetta qui l'accaparé
langue au chat tout les maxima niasse a
avoué qu en sélectionner qu'un
sélectionné comme sélectionneur
orji du sonos collectionner match aller
on arrive à tous et toutes en moto cours
moto bleue cateau dynamité commun le
vélo était presque 100% de venise qui
comme stéphane y as tes amis du tourisme
impossible pour l'hôtelière d'envisager
l'avenir sans retour des voyageurs
mais les derniers mois l'ont convaincu
que la préco vide doit faire apparaître
un tourisme plus raisonnée voire
raisonnable un tourisme avec moins de
grands navires de croisière mois de
pollution
[Musique]
alessandro sartori milite depuis
longtemps pour repenser l'accueil des
touristes
l'enit colloque propose des séjours
touristiques écologiques avec la
fermeture forcée de venise il a retrouvé
une tong maîtresse de la lagune et des
marais de nouvelles espèces comme cette
stern migratrices s'ils sont posées pour
nous c'est clairement que chris mckenzie
c'est le risque qu'une opportunité
évidente est que le modèle au
touristique aux divas et ja non plus
générale problème de sa mort touristique
d'el mundo va registre et la digestion
déterminer combien d'amendés
soutenabilité venus comme comco met
maintenant mais rappelle un peu dans la
guerre elle était dans la galette
évident de la personne directeur de
l'abps de la guerre
de là les stars pour tout ça y est
maintenant il ya deux mois c'était la
même chose à rigautou prix annie est
propriétaire de deux restaurants et bars
à venise bien qu'il ait besoin de
retrouver les touristes pour relancer
ces entreprises ce qui le désole ce
n'est pas l'exode soudain des visiteurs
mais celui plus lent et durable des
citoyens de sa ville au cours de la
dernière décennie la population de
venise a fondu cinquante trois mille
habitants de tous deux villes du monde
sont faits des pierres et des ses
citoyens
moi je me rappelle la vie de venise tant
aidé à 30 ans c'était magnifique roman
magnifique des choses qu'il faut
apprendre de ça c'est dépenser vraiment
de faire tourner des gens avec des
jeunes mais les jeunes vénitien comme
marco est tous dans la foule compacte
qui envahit venise en temps normal c'est
un stress constant que tous ses copains
de classe non plus voulu en dur et de
ses amis d'enfance
il est le seul à être resté depuis deux
mois il redécouvre une venise dont il se
souvenait à peine les il croit que son
fils n'échappera pas à l'appel du large
ce sera quand bien même tu aurais
vraiment mal
nomi pas qu'il fallait faire ces
programmes et cela comme un outil si
delanoë y apprendre à se rendre à
quelque part tu as réalisé we are tmx
dans une autre claque sont avisés à nos
questions à mon rival au camp nou lé
modo que si tu seras débarquer chez
c'est l'avertissement semble futile ces
jours ci alberto risque peu de se
retrouver dans les embouteillages au
détour du grand canal
c'est un délice pour le vénitien de
naissance qu'il est les un drame pour
son métier de gondoles
[Musique]